ZPD's first rabbit officer,...
Judy Hopps.
Ready to make the world a better place?
Bad news in this city gripped by fear.
What can you tell us about the animals that went savage?
Are we safe?
This is priority one.
Hopps, parking duty.
Sir, I'm not just some token bunny.
You strike out, you resign.
Deal.
I have 36 hours left, we can only solve it together.
It's not about how badly you want something,...
...it's about what you are capable of.
I am a real cop.
Never let them see that they get to you.
You bunnies, so emotional.
No, no, no, do not let go!
I'm gonna let go.
What?!
No matter what type of animal you are, change starts with you.
We gotta go.
Whose car is it?
The most feared crime boss - Mr. Big.